the Trump team is Raging over poll
numbers that increasingly show Donald
Trump failing in swing states where Ron
Des Sanctus is actually doing pretty
well a survey from Republican firm
public opinion strategies shows that
DeSantis who isn't even officially
running yet but is expected to announce
soon would beat Biden in Arizona and
Pennsylvania in a hypothetical 2024
Face-Off by 48-42 and 45 to 42. the
Trump uh War Room account is just
attacking the poll they put out a tweet
saying truly a POS poll now I have to
tell you the reality is this is not a
unique result I've been telling you for
a while that the polling suggests that
while Trump is doing really well in the
primary polling DeSantis does better
against Biden in much of the general
election polling